connecter les anciens de connecter donc
c'est son assistant personnel qui dans
votre maison vous permettent de voir la
météo d'avoir de joindre marc landré
cimer au téléphone vous l'avez
numériquement enfin toutes sortes de
choses dans ce genre alex a donc c'est
le nom pour amazon
on a posé la question c'était alexa
qu'est ce qu'un gilet jaune alors à la
question à lexar époux réponse et un
gilet de sécurité
mais c'est aussi un mouvement social
d'un qui a commencé en france en
novembre 2018
ces enceintes sont les trous beaucoup
aux états unis si vous voulez en savoir
plus vous recommande une enquête qui est
publié par le site les jours sur ce
sujet avec un journaliste qui raconte
ses six mois passés en cohabitation avec
une enceinte
donc vous avez dit que pas chez moi marc
voulait c'est cet hybride qui coûte de
ce mal français de vouloir tout et son
contraire on veut être moderne on veut
être technologique
on se bat pour les données personnelles
parce qu'on veut pas vendre nos données
à google aux gaffes à et on va aller
acheter qu'on va les acheter à noël des
anciens de connecter partout qui vont
enregistrer tout ce qu'on fait qui vont
collecter tous les données connues
personnel du correspondant qui après
vont les vendre à des grands sites
capitalistes internationaux qui vont se
faire du beurre sur notre dos voilà ce
truc que c'est la schizophrénie parfaite
classique des français a prôné avec son
temps l'américain qui a cédé
moi j'en ai acheté année pour noël
saille tout le monde parce que je vous
explique vis à vis à vis parce que ce
qui est merveilleux c'est google je fais
la promo de google parce que google la
grosse m'énervait un petit peur mais
google a fait des toutes petites
alors voilà je veux dire à l'avant pour
quoi et alors est ce que honnêtement sur
l'idée qu' on est on est on est
on est espionné on récolte donné c'est
déjà fait je veux dire c'est déjà trop
tarder pour lutter dont on est dans un
monde où tout le monde c'est surtout
tout sur tout le monde tout le monde
écoute tout le monde se sert à rien de
se récrier quand la nasa écoute ou line
est sympa ton écoute je dis à tout le
monde s'en fout oh oh on est déçu mais
c'est pas évident alors je termine mon
laissez moi finir donc je te dis juste
gingras 27 août s'exprime se dire que
moi j'en ai acheté déjà j'en offre à
tout le monde et je vais en avoir une
parce que je trouve que il va falloir
quand même que on s'habitue à vivre dans
ce monde dans 20 ans on aura des robots
il ya déjà le petit robot vous savez qui
fille passe super bien respirateur je
conseille aux filles qui nous écoutent
c'est le fait pas je vois pas qui nous
écoutent ce roman ce robot est
magnifique il va lui même il retourne
lui-même sur son support de chargement
il contourne etc ça vaut 150 d'accord ok
je sais pas quoi aussi ces demandes de
sécession
je vous promets chanter à la parole mais
c'était pour une petite un clin d'oeil
pour pour françoise pascal excès quand
on lui demande comment ça va regarder ce
qu'elle répond ce moment avec ça
comment ça va très bien c'est le moment
de ne plus penser au passé lié au futur
mais juste au présent
je parle bien sûr des cadeaux de noël
qu'il soit matériel ou de simples
intentions elle et que ça vous demande
vous recommander le même d'aller faire
vos cadeaux jacky isabello sur ces
sujets pour tout savoir là dessus sur
l'intelligence artificielle il ya une
futurologue le terme et pas très beau
qui tous les ans aux états unis
s'appelle amy webb
elle donne des conférences pour les
journalistes américains elle leur
explique un peu ce qui peut se passer si
l'intelligence artificielle est dévoyée
est juste là tuez-le dit attention à la
voix parce qu'il ya un point qui est
important c'est que la voix va
mécaniquement dans la tête des gens
supprimer quelque chose qui pour vous
journalistes est fondamental c'est
l'identification de la source
c'est-à-dire que quand on lit un journal
on veut la source la télé mais la source
la voix elle vous dit pas source le
figaro et sahamies web explique effet
des scénarios en disant voilà si c'est
mal utilisé voilà ce qui pourrait passer
intérêts
et plus que ça elle explique alors c'est
pas du tout une catastrophiste s'est
elle est au service du journal
et ça cartonne et elle explique elle
explique la manière dont ça pourrait
perturber un peu l'organisation
démocratique si on ne maîtrise pas ça
quand ils mamour une enceinte connecter
chez vous non ça ne sert à rien je
trouve que en coton voilà les questions
qu'on pose c'est comment allez-vous ça
sert si c'est pour poser sa non mais
est-ce que je peux parler on peut se
demander si c'est bien dit miller si
c'est pour leur demander ce genre de
questions ou allumer la lumière ou etc
ça n'a aucun intérêt en revanche il est
évident que les problèmes de vie privée
sont importants et le législateur ne
s'en occupe pas les problèmes
d'intrusion policière ou d'espionnage
sont très importants et personne ne s'en
occupe et sa cdc des dossiers dont les
pouvoirs publics devraient se saisir par
anticipation justement on sait bien que
les technologies ont une dimension
totalitaire c'est une dimension
extrêmement séduisante de services au
quotidien pour chacun on en a envie mais
il ya une dimension de totalitaire
qu'ils gravent sur l'utilisation des
données il ya eu l'exemple aux états
unis où il aura une assimilation des
dossiers la personne de son amende et
alix c'était exact des réquisitions de
avoir le manger une fatalité
je fais du je pratique le fatah
disposition cette question j'espère une
voiture reste peut lire tout seul et que
quelqu'un peut s'en emparer et henry
dans un platane on met ça je t'assure
que le fatalisme et je passe quelques
réactions de nos internautes à avoir
qu'avec les avions bien sûr à voir
amazon difficile marqué soyez un peu
disciplinés à voir amazon qui m'écoutent
toute la journée certainement pas nous
disent chiche super lama l'évolution
technologique n'est pas encore assez
bonne pour moi
sandra nous dit pas d'espions à la
maison qu'est ce que ne peuvent pas
faire les soldes n'ont pas le droit
d'écouter ses il faut vous donner
l'autorisation mais là où c'est
important
c'est un point juste pour dire aux
auditeurs c'est que on est dans une
période qu'on appelle encore une photo
de nadj marketing aujourd'hui la
communication est les plus autoritaires
comme le faisait la publicité
aujourd'hui elle vous stimule c'est à
dire qu'elle va vous dire gentiment elle
va un style et des choses celle ayant
déclenché les comportements et en fait
si on a toutes les deux
et il a raison si on a toutes les
données des dîners des données très
pointue et bien on peut vous donner la
petite information qui va bien et à ce
moment là tout seul
vous pensez que vous avez pris
l'addition n'oubliez jamais une chaîne à
estaires vous m'auriez ambiance et la
publicité a un impact sur eux ils vous
disent pas sur moi absolument exactes ne
sont pas encore terminées aujourd'hui le
dernier mot c'est l omi des annonces est
terminée pas vous elle a le dernier mot
à blueberry cake à la place de macron on
met alex à point d'interrogation
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis et puis un
petit hommage à joseph joffo l'auteur
d'un sac de billes qui est mort
aujourd'hui le sac de billes écrit en
1973 et qui a sans doute séduit bien des
générations
à demain pour un nouveau point de vue
courjault
[Musique]